back everyone
so this is cs229 lecture 14.
the topic for today we'll be starting a
new chapter is
reinforcement learning and today we'll
be covering
markov decision processes value
iteration and and policy iteration
uh which form probably the core of
reinforcement learning
and um in in friday's lecture we'll see
more complex extensions of this
and before we jump into today's topics
uh a few
announcements so uh for those of you
who've been
sending in feedback through the google
forms that we submitted
thank you so much there are um we got a
lot of good suggestions a lot of
points where we can improve and i would
like to uh briefly summarize
you know some of the feedback that we've
got and the kind of steps that we'll be
taking to
um to improve so
uh one of the uh concerns raised was
office hours uh that there are uh there
were a few too many
last minute changes for office hours um
and we will try to do our best not to
change the office our schedule moving
forward
unfortunately sometimes there may be
personal emergencies or things beyond
the ts control
when it's too late to bring in a
replacement ta but
those exceptions apart we will do our
best to keep the office our schedule
fixed
there were also a few very specific
comments and suggestions about
the way the office hours were were
conducted and
we noticed what you what you've said and
we'll be
definitely taking steps to improve and
a few more uh comments from from you
guys
so a few comments on the lectures so
some of you have asked for
uh doing the lectures with the slides
format where we are projecting slides
and
um and and doing the lectures around the
slides
uh however uh this is a pretty matty
class
and um at least it's my opinion that
um you know slides might not be the best
approach because there'll be a lot of
back and forth between going on the
slide and going on the backboard and
that can be pretty distracting for
somebody who's watching the videos
and also uh we just tend you know um
probably math is better explained on a
whiteboard than on on on slides
uh several of you have asked that i
write bigger on the whiteboard uh thank
you for that feedback i will
make a conscious decision to write
bigger if any of you
uh have any trouble understanding what's
written on the whiteboard
please stop me right right then and you
know tell me that you cannot see it i
will i will you know
i have no problem erasing it and writing
all over again
and also uh some of you have mentioned
that the lectures are going too slow
some of you have mentioned it's going
too fast
um so the the uh
so i guess one one way to kind of
accommodate both
needs of going fast and going too slow
uh is probably that
uh uh i i think a good good compromise
there would be to
probably postpone some of the questions
that that come from the audience
to a few in a batched way so hold off
till i you know complete some section
and then ask your question in case
your question gets answered right then
and if if the questions are not
directly related to the lecture itself
then i might
ask you to just post the question on
piazza and when i ask you to post it on
queer
on piazza it will be uh it's it's a
sincere request that you actually do
post it on piazza because you know i
want to answer them uh and
just not hold you know the hundred or
more of you
you know waiting while i answer the
questions that may be of interest to a
few of you
um and then uh some of you have also
uh given some feedback about the
difficulty of homeworks
so some find the math in it too hard
some of you find the programming in it
too hard
and i don't know if there is
a clear action that we can take over
there because
machine learning is is indeed um you
know a field that
that spans computer science and
statistics so it will be hard on math it
will be hard on programming
and it's that's just the nature of of
you know machine learning
and uh the programming assignments
uh or the the uh homework assignments
might feel a little too
long um however uh you know
in this course we are just following the
the uh
the following the pattern that has been
followed for this course in the previous
quarters right and
and and the programming uh assignments
and the homework assignments you know in
each homework is not more or less than
what's been done before and and that's
just
the way the course is structured it is
it is a work workload heavy course
uh in terms of um in terms of help
required for programming
uh in general in office hours we tend
not to focus on helping students debug
their code
we expect students to be comfortable
with programming and be able to just
implement things on your own
however going forward if if there is no
backlog in the queue you know the tas
will
might probably help you a little bit if
there is nobody else waiting
uh but in general the expectation for
the course is that you come with
you know basic computer programming
skills and
you have no no problems writing simple
code given an algorithm
uh but at the same time we don't want to
um you know um kind of
leave you stuck if you're having some
trouble so you know try attending office
if you're especially if you need help
in programming try attending office
hours early in the homework phase so
that office hours are free and maybe tas
can help you out there
if you if you attend office hours when
the deadline to homework is is
you know close then the tas will have a
hard time helping you with with
programming um
and for those of you who you know the
the the
feedback form is still open uh i i'm
still going to keep checking for it
every once in a while if you have any
feedbacks you know please feel free to
give us candid feedbacks on how we can
improve and we'll do our best to
you know make changes and accommodate as
many needs as possible
okay with that let's start with a quick
recap of
um of
the last lecture and also do a quick
summary of where we are standing in
terms of the overall course
so in the last lecture or the last two
lectures we've been
talking quite a bit about bias variance
trade-off
and this understanding this bias
variance tradeoff in a deep way
should probably be the highest priority
for you of what you take away from this
course
right biased radius variance tradeoff is
something that is so fundamental and
understanding it
in an intuitive and deep way will be
will probably serve you the longest
it has probably the largest payoff into
your future machine learning career
right so uh to summarize uh bias
variance trade-off
in machine learning we are interested in
generalization error
right how well our model performs on
unseen data
not on the training data that we have
and the test error or the generalization
error can be
decomposed into three parts three
additive parts
so one is irreducible error and this is
just the noise in the test example right
our training data is noisy and our test
data is noisy
and the noise in the in the in the test
data is what contributes to irreducible
error and there's nothing we can do
about it
it's just a fact of life and we accept
it and then there are these two other
components called bias and variance
bias you can think of it as a systematic
error of your model which means
if you average it across all the
possible training sets that you can get
the the systematic error that your model
makes that's either your under
predicting or overpredicting for certain
examples or that your
parameters are closer to zero than what
it should be
that systematic error is called bias
and variance is how sensitive our model
is
to noise in the training data right and
this is where the distinction between
noise and the test data and the training
data comes into picture
noise in the test data contributes to
irreducible error
and that's you know one component of the
generalization error and noise in the
training data contributes to the
variance of
of your model right and
the steps that we can take to reduce
the test error the steps that we can
take there are way too many steps that
you can take for example
you can try a bigger model you can try
you can get more training data there are
many steps that you can take
however not all the steps work all the
time
and in order to determine what steps
what what is the step that is most
effective for the problem
that is immediately in front of you in
order to make that decision
it's very crucial that you understand
this bias variance trade off
right reducing training error is is
simple you can always
you know get a bigger model get a more
complex
model and that will reduce your training
error but our goal is to improve on test
error
and and and the steps that we take as i
said already is going to is going to
depend
on whether the current problem that
you're facing is mostly a bias problem
or is it mostly a variance problem
right and the bias variance trade off
basically tells you
that by taking some step you may be
reducing
you know one of them either bias or
variance but that may also increase the
other
right and which is why it is very
important that we
that we are able to characterize which
of the two problems is the bigger
problem
at hand and take a step to purposefully
go after that particular problem
either bias or variance right for
example we saw that
if we if we increa increase the model
capacity if you move to a more complex
model
that will reduce the bias
of of your model but at the same time it
may increase the variance of your model
right so if if the problem that you're
facing right now is high variance
then you should almost certainly not use
a bigger model because that is going to
worsen the problem that you have
right and similarly with regularization
if we increase regularization
that is going to reduce the variance in
the model but it's going to increase the
it's also going to increase the bias in
the uh in the model which means
if your problem right now is high bias
then increasing regularization
is going to make it worse whereas
increasing regularization would have
helped
if the problem was high variance right
which is why it is super super important
for you to characterize and get a
heuristic estimate
of what the contribution of bias is
towards our
and what the contribution of variance is
towards the current uh
test error and unfortunately there is no
principled approach to decompose and get
these estimates in practice
which is why we use heuristics right the
heuristics are
you can think of the training error
itself as the bias
and you can think of the gap between
cross validation error and training
error as variance
and this is where cross validation comes
into picture cross validation
is necessary or the the
the most important use of cross
validation is that we can get this
this decomposition of various variance
and bias from the current model
right and and once we get this we get
this
breakdown we can then make a judgment
about whether a model is currently
facing a larger bias problem or a larger
variance problem
and take some remedial step according to
which of the two is larger
right so the the summary is that
whenever you are
working on model development and you
want to improve your model performance
you should always always always look at
the training error
and cross-validation error
simultaneously right
we care about improving the cross
validation error or the
or the test error but just looking at
that alone
will give you nothing actionable in
order to have something
actionable you need to see both the
training error and the cross validation
error simultaneously
make a judgment about whether the
situation is a high bias situation or a
high variance situation
and then accordingly take some action to
remedy the high bias or high variance
right then this this is probably the the
most important
thing that's going to serve you well for
the rest of your machine learning career
right so that's that's the bias variance
tradeoff
and to kind of take a larger look of
where we are standing in terms of the
overall course
so here's here's a a
a rough overview or a quick overview of
what we've covered so far
so approximately week one through four
we cover
supervised learning and what is
supervised learning supervised learning
is learning some function h which you
call the hypothesis
that maps x to y right
there is there is this clear concept of
input and output in supervised learning
which will not be the case in
unsupervised learning in supervised
learning there's a very clear
sense of what is input and what's output
and we have noisy examples
of input output pairs right and most of
the time the noise
is embedded in the label what we call in
in the output
and we get a training set of size n
of you know these these xy pairs and
from this training set
our goal is to learn this hypothesis
that
that's a function that maps x to y such
it generalizes well to unseen data right
there is some notion of a loss function
and we want to minimize this loss
function on unseen data
right if the problem was just to
minimize it on the given data that we
have
then we would just call it an
optimization problem
right but this is machine learning
because we want to do well on unseen
data right and that's
that's where you know the concept of
bias variance come into picture
and we thought uh we've been seeing you
know
approximately you know two kinds of
algorithms classification versus
regression
and this this categorization is based on
the data type
of the y variable right if the data type
of the y variable
is binary you know zero or one then we
call it classification
and this could not be just binary but it
could be you know
or multiple class like you know um for
example in the homework you're you're
you're
building a classifier for 100 digits for
mnist where
y can take anything between you know
zero to nine
and that is called classification where
y is discrete
and in cases where y is continuous we
call it regression
right and we have seen you know simple
two very simple
models that we started off with that was
linear regression
and logistic regression for uh for for
regression problems and classification
problems
and then we after after seeing those two
we kind of generalized
the the data type of y to not just you
know be this
strict regression versus classification
but
generalize them into something called
glms generalized linear models
where y given x is some distribution in
the exponential family
right it could be discrete it could be
continuous it could be
poisson which is just integers it could
be anything it could be you know
positive
only and as long as that y given x
distribution
is belongs to the exponential family
then
we can solve it with with you know
common update rules and you know
there were other niceties that we saw so
generalized linear models
is not just for classification or for
regression or for poisson
it generalizes the data type of y
to any any kind of data type essentially
right and then we also saw two different
uh
kinds of approaches for building models
discriminative
versus generative and discriminative
models we are directly learning y given
x
so generalized linear model is an
example of a discriminative model
where we are only interested in learning
the probability distribution of y
when the corresponding x is given to you
and the the other approach for building
models is called generative models
where we want to learn how to generate
new examples how to
generate a full pair x y pair right
and this can be generally broken down
using the chain rule as p of y
times p of x given y and
we saw a few examples of of generative
models so we saw a naive bayes
where x was discrete and we saw gda
gaussian discriminant analysis where x
was real valued
right and we also saw that
ah with with with gda
there is a one-to-one correspondence
between
gda and logistic regression in fact for
any x given y where x belongs to
exponential family
p of y given x will always take a
logistic regression form right and we
saw that in the homework as well
and then we moved on to nonlinear models
right the
what we we actually did explore
non-linearity using feature maps in your
homework already in the first homework
where you try different feature maps
we get non-linear hypotheses right
and the the
more formal approach to feature maps
that we saw was kernels
right kernels are are these you know
symmetric positive definite functions
which have an implicit feature map
embedded in them and using kernels we
can we can build
uh you know kernel based methods you
know we call them kernel methods
and we saw two such examples support
vector machines for classification
problems
and gaussian processes for regression
problems both of these methods
use kernels and svm
in particular was was you know
particularly well suited
for a kernel method and that was because
with with um with the non-kernel based
approaches
the complexity of the model depends on
the number of parameters that we have
that depends on the number of features
that we have
whereas with kernel methods the the
complexity depends on the number of
examples that we have
right those those are the two two kind
of sides of your
design matrix with with normal models we
learn
one parameter per feature that is per
column and with kernel methods we learn
one coefficient for example you know per
row
and so kernel methods in general
tend not to work so well when the number
of examples is a lot when you have a
very big
data set kernel methods tend to
tend to be more expensive and we saw
that in svms in particular
the set of coefficients that we learned
for
with the kernel approach happens to be
sparse which means you get the best of
both worlds you get good scalability
in the number of features because
kernels can potentially give you
infinite number of features
and you also get good scalability in
terms of number of examples because the
coefficients are
mostly zero and even with large data
sets therefore svms tend to work well
right and then we moved on to another
kind of non-linearity so
you know kernel methods was one and the
other approach that we
that we saw was learnable features where
in in the first approach the feature map
or the kernel is hand designed
you decide what the kernel you want to
use is
the other approach is to again use data
to learn what are good feature maps
right that's where neural networks came
into picture
right with neural networks you can think
of neural network as
a generalized linear model at the last
layer and everything before that
as some kind of a learnable feature map
right and after that we moved on to
learning theory and in learning theory
the the main topics that we touched upon
was regularization
and it's its bayesian interpretation of
how
regularization uh corresponds to
performing map estimation in the in the
bayesian setting
and we saw um we studied bias and
variance and the bias
variance trade off which which we
covered already
and we also studied uniform convergence
right so uniform convergence is a more
theoretical theoretical
part of the course and in general you
know
understanding the contents of you know
the lecture notes on uniform convergence
and what we covered in the lecture
can be very useful if you're interested
in getting into machine learning
research because you know that's that's
like the common framework in which most
of the machine learning
uh theory problems are posed
and that's until the last lecture
so we are here right now right
and today and in the next lecture we'll
be covering reinforcement learning it's
going to be a very quick
overview of reinforcement learning we
will not be going very deep
there are multiple courses uh offered
only on reinforcement learning you know
it's a super vast uh uh
field and but we'll only be covering
just the basics and giving you
kind of you know a big picture or a mind
map of how the
different reinforcement learning
algorithms that we are not going to
cover how they all kind of fit together
in one
one piece so that's the plan for
reinforcement learning and
starting next week we will be starting
unsupervised learning
for me personally i like unsupervised
learning the most um
it's it's um i know it's it's very
exciting
and once we kind of finish up with
unsupervised learning we're going to
cover
some general topics you know things like
you know evaluation metrics maybe a few
a few theoretical ideas like kl
divergence or a few such things some
some general topics
that don't kind of you know fit into
this you know supervised versus
unsupervised classification
and finally in the last week uh on week
eight we'll have only two
lectures on the monday and the and the
wednesday and those two lectures will be
doing a full review of the entire course
again
with the hope that it prepares you well
for the final exam
right so any questions before we move
into today's
uh today's topic of reinforcement
learning yes questions
so the question is why are these two uh
why is wise training error and
approximation of bias and
cross-validation
i would say you know post that on piazza
um and and you know i'll be happy to
kind of give you more give you more
details on that all right so let's let's
start with
um reinforcement learning
so in the in the in the examples that
uh in in the topics that we've covered
so far which has been mostly supervised
learning
we were always told for a given input or
for a given situation what the correct
answer is
right so for every x we had a
corresponding y
which was the correct answer or the the
the answer that
our model should learn to predict and
that was given directly to us
right and which is which is why we
called it supervised learning
right whereas in reinforcement learning
this kind of supervision is a little
weak
instead of telling us what to do in a
given situation
we are instead given some kind of a
reward right
so in in rl we
you know one way to think of it is
replace
y which is supervision with reward
right and reward is always a real value
it could be positive it could be
negative
and the way you want to think of reward
is kind of
um how good a job you did right
there is no right reward so to speak you
know
you there is there is no um
there is no optimal reward uh
as such and the goal in in reinforcement
learning
is to kind of maximize
our long-term reward which means we are
dealing with situations
which are changing over time right in
supervised learning we were dealing with
fixed situations
and each example was what we call as iid
where each example was independent of
the other
whereas in reinforcement learning we are
trying
to trying to program an agent that kind
of
lives in in an environment or in the
real world or in a simulator
that performs well over time and
examples of of of such agents could be
you know for example it could be
um a robot which is learning how to walk
it could be a game-playing agent that
plays chess or go
it could be even some kind of an
automated trading agent that you you
know um
that you that you use in a financial
market right
things where you're making multiple
decisions over time
and at each time after you make every uh
after you take every action you get some
kind of a reward right
and the the goal with with reinforcement
learning
is to maximize this accumulated reward
over time
right which means we need to take this
long term view
of trying to optimize how how much
reward we're going to accumulate
starting from now all the way into the
future right which is very different
from the supervised learning setting
where in supervised learning
setting we were given an example and our
only concern was to do well on that
example alone
and the next example was completely
independent
right and so it is this this concept of
time
that makes reinforcement learning
different from
general supervised learning right in
reinforcement learning we are making
multiple decisions once one decision at
one decision at a time
and with each decision we are earning
some reward
and our goal is to maximize this
accumulated reward
into the future and the way we kind of
formalize reinforcement learning is
through
this formalism called mdp or markov
decision process
or call decision process
fdp right so an mdp
is
it is ah is ah
one two three it's a five tuple it is a
tuple
containing five things
s a
p s a
gamma and r
where s
is a set of states
it is the set of all possible states
that our agent can
can currently be in
a is a set
of actions
right p s
a are transition probabilities
gamma this is
zero to one discount factor
and r just
s cross
is called the reward function
right now lets lets look at an example
of what all of these actually mean
supposing ah this example comes from a
very famous textbook on
on artificial intelligence and its also
very
standard example used in many courses so
you might have seen this before
so supposing there is this
right supposing this is there is this
agent that lives in some kind of a map
some kind of a region
where your agent at any given time
can be in one of these grids
and our goal is to reach here
and ah and you get a reward of plus one
if you reach here and you get a reward
of minus one if you reach here
and our goal is to is to ah
is to be able to solve this and by what
i mean by solving is
so first of all what is s s is the set
of all possible states where our agent
can be so
states in this case s
in this case is the set you know 1 1
1 2 and so on
and the size of this the size of
our state space in this case is 11
it can be in 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 and you know this is blocked you
cannot be in the state
the set of actions that we can take in
this case
are to move our agent one step at a time
in any of the direction so the set of
actions we take can be
move north move south move west
or move east right four simple actions
that we can take
and the probability psa is also called
the transition probability
what this means is this is a probability
distribution
over the states and what this
specifically means is if we are in
one particular state that indexed by s
and we take an action index by a then
what is the probability
that we are going to end up in one of
the other states
right so it is a probability
distribution over the state space
and it has two indices the current state
and the action that we are taking
so for example if you're if you're
building a robot
that has to move in this kind of a map
if the
robot is in is in ah one three
then p 1 3
and let's say the action that we take is
go north
north so this is p s a state
is you know the state we are in 1 3 and
action we take is go north
then this will be a probability
distribution
such that ah
let us say there is there is you know
some kind of uncertainty in the robot
and whenever we ask it to go
north with let's say with 80 probability
it actually goes north
and with a 10 percent probability it
goes west and with 10 percent
probability it goes east
right so this will be a probability
distribution
that has zeros everywhere
point one that corresponds to the state
one four right
one two
point eight corresponding to the state
two three
and zeros everywhere
right is this clear for for every state
we take an action
and when we take an action we can end up
in a new state
and that the that transition of moving
to the next state
is stochastic and that stochasticity
that stochasticity is captured
by this probability distribution which
tells us
with what probability we are going to
end up in any given state
depending on what action we took and
what state we were currently in
this question
yeah i'll come to that i'll come to that
so uh uh so
let's for you know simplicity assume we
can take any action in any state for now
right so uh so that's that's called a
transition probability and then there is
something called
ah the discount factor gamma will come
to that
and there is a reward function so a
reward function
is basically uh the reward that our
agent
earns immediately after you know
when it is in some particular state for
example if
if our agent comes to this state where
we you know want it to be it earns a
reward of plus one
and if you wanted to avoid the state it
earns a reward of minus 1
right and let us say you know the reward
at all the other places
is a small negative reward 0.02
minus you know 0.02 minus 0.4
and so on right and these are the
immediate rewards
that the model gets or the agent gets
for entering a particular state
and most of the times the reward
function is
represented as a function of the state
you know gives you some
ah real valued reward and sometimes it
is also
modeled as r of s comma a
where when you are in a particular state
and you take the next action a you get
some particular reward
the reason why sometimes uh we tend to
model
model it as a state action pair rather
than state alone
is because taking uh taking different
actions may have different costs
so uh even though you earned the same
reward for being in a state the fact
that you took one action over another
you may be paying a different cost
so you know to to account for such
action-specific costs you know it's it
and sometimes you would
model the reward function as as a
function over the state action pair
rather than just a state alone
but for uh in terms of what we are going
to cover
most of the times we'll be just focusing
on
reward functions as a function of state
and assume that all actions have equal
questions yes question
yeah so in practice how do we know we
will get to that we know it's it's it's
part of how we
define the uh problems itself
um yeah so that's the reward function
and
in terms of in terms of uh
what happens when we start an agent we
assume that the agent is going to start
in
some initial state s s naught
so let's assume that the agent starts at
some initial state
s naught and we take an action a
or a naught that is the first action
taken by
the agent and by taking an action
a at a state s we enter a new state
s1 which is according to
the transition probabilities so s 1 is
now
s one is sampled from p of
s zero a zero right and once we are in s
one
we take action a one and
enter state s two where s two is sampled
from
p of s to
s one a one right
and then we take action a two enter s
three
no action a three and so on
right this sequence of
states and actions is commonly called
there are multiple names that you will
see in in in different books or
different resources
you can either call it a trial
or you can call it an episode
or trajectory
right all these are you know synonymous
for
a sequence of states and actions are
taken by an agent
where the action is taken by the agent
and the environment lands you
in the new state according to the
transition probabilities yes question
so the question is why is uh
the probability of going north when we
are in one three a vector
yeah so um in general so so
the way to think of reinforcement
learning is you are in an agent
that lives in some kind of an
environment right you are in one
particular state and you take an action
and by taking an action you end up in
another state
but the state that you end up in can be
random
right so let's say you are building a
robot and in your robot you
ask the robot to move north and for
whatever reason maybe there's a stone
under its wheel or maybe there are some
some things that
are beyond our control your robot may
end up going to a different location
than the one
that you are then you were actually
interested in maybe you ask your robot
to
move you know a meter in one direction
but in reality it may end up moving say
95 centimeters or 105 centimeters
right so there is some stochasticity in
the environment
due to which we always don't go to the
same state that we
that an action will not always take you
to the same state all the time
right and that is why here if you are in
you know one three and you
you know ah and your and you go north
most of the times you will go to two
three with probability you know point
eight but sometimes you may go to you
know one two or you may go to one four
so
either here or here the probability
point one but you know most of the times
you end up going no
that's that's the general idea this
question
yeah so so i i think you're talking
about about a game playing where there
is an opponent
uh so uh i i'll push that question until
later
uh for now let's assume we are you know
the environment is stochastic for
whatever reason
right um yeah so it could be if you're
in if you're in
in a game playing scenario it could be
due to the opponent um
so um yeah so this this we call it as a
as a trial or an episode or a trajectory
and all three are all three names are
synonymous
and now what we what we ah when
when an agent goes through a particular
trajectory
at each state s it is earning some
reward
so over here it earns rfs naught
when it lands in state s1
the agent earns r of s1 right
from here r of s2 so
the agent is accumulating rewards at
each step
right and
the and this is where the discount
factor comes into picture right
so the discount factor is basically a
factor
which we multiply all future rewards by
so the reward for being in state
s1 will be discounted by a factor gamma
the rewarded state s 2 will be
discounted by a factor gamma square
the reward from s 3
will be discounted by a factor gamma q
and what the agent
what the agent accumulates over the
future
is basically the sum of these discounted
rewards
right and this is
and this sum of accumulated rewards is
what we want to maximize
and the the idea here the reason why we
call it discount factor
is one way to think of it is
any positive reward that we get is
better obtained sooner rather than later
right
so the discount factor incentivizes
the model to earn larger rewards sooner
and it also incentivizes the model to
postpone any negative rewards into the
future right that's one way to think of
it
another common interpretation of the
discount factor especially if you're in
a finance
setting is you can think of the discount
factor as
interest rate right which means uh you
want to you want to earn your
money sooner rather than later and you
want to postpone your losses
into the future rather than you know
rather than sooner
right next question uh with respect to
game
doesn't that lead to some optimal
strategies well so
let's let's push game game playing you
know we'll cover
environment right we'll gameplay game
game planning
yeah so we we're gonna we're gonna touch
upon exactly that
that that topic of you know
sub-optimality
right so uh this is this is the uh
setting
in which uh the the
agent operates so we want to design uh
an agent
that given this markov decision process
wants to or needs to maximize the sum of
accumulated rewards into the future
right
and these rewards are discounted by a
discount factor gamma
and this discount factor gamma um
there are many many uh good reasons to
have this discount factor gamma but
some of the interpretation is you can
think of this gamma as you know interest
rate
or you can think of it as a motivation
to
make the agent get reward sooner rather
than later yes question
yeah it's it's uh the gamma is the same
gamma that we use at all time steps
yes there's a particular reason uh we'll
we'll um
we're going to we'll cover this in a
shortly why why we're going to use the
same camera
right so now ah given this
given this setting we can define
two central concepts
right and these two concepts are going
to
are going to stay with us for the rest
of reinforcement learning
right so
so we are going to define something
called as a policy
pie which is mapping from
state to action
so the policy tells you what action to
take when you are in a given state right
and this is the policy over which
the agent has flexibility to learn right
our goal is to learn a policy we want to
learn this function
that maps us from state to action and
we want to learn a policy that is going
to maximize something called as the
value
right so the value associated with the
policy pi
is a function that takes us from a state
to real valued
where v pi
of s is defined as
expectation of
r of s naught
plus gamma times
r of s one plus
gamma square times r of s2
so on until
s naught equals s comma
so we define the value of a state by
following a particular policy
to be the sum of all the
expected rewards from starting from the
first state all the way you know
until until infinity where
each reward at a particular time step is
discounted by the corresponding gamma
factor
right and over over here ah
the the s which is the parameter of the
value function
decides what is the starting state could
be right so
the value of the value of a particular
state by following a policy pi
is the discounted sum of all future
rewards
assuming we start at the given state
and the actions that we take at each
step
is according to the policy
that that is given to us right you start
at a given state
start taking actions according to a
policy the environment based on the
transition probabilities is going to
keep throwing you to different states
and when you go to a new state refer to
your policy and take the next action
and you know you keep going to new
states and as you are going to
as you are going from one state to
another you are accumulating rewards
and we discount each of those rewards by
the corresponding gamma factor right and
the value of a particular value of a
policy at a given state
is this expected sum of future words and
the reason why we use expectation here
is because these rewards
are random the reason why the rewards
are random
is because the state that we end up in
is random
and this reason why the state that we
end up in is random
is because of the transition
probabilities right
so if the transition probabilities were
not stochastic
so if we always reach the same state
when we took a particular action every
time
then we would not need this expectation
but because the transitions are
stochastic
we are the values defined as the
expected
sum of future rewards or some of future
discounted rewards
any questions about this yes question
so this is a comma
right so this is this is ah this is
called the value function
and this is called the policy right and
as we will see probably tomorrow you
know these two concepts
are are kind of they are at the heart of
reinforcement learning
because you can kind of classify the
entire field of reinforcement learning
into those that try to optimize
or learn good value functions versus
those that directly try to learn
policies right so
this this uh these two are central
concepts that that we're going to
encounter over and over and it's this
value
function that is um
that's related to rewards but also it is
different from rewards
so reward is you know you can think of
reward as like the
reward is the immediate reward that you
get by just entering into a state
whereas value is you can think of
value as the long-term benefit or the
sum of
all future rewards that you're going to
accumulate by following a particular
policy
so reward you can think of it as
short-sighted you know something that
you're going to get immediately by
going into a particular state whereas
you know value is
is like the long-term value by following
a particular policy
this question so the value keeps
changing right um
depending on where you are in the next
state so even in the first stage um
is always taken at where you are at the
moment and therefore your value is
shifting
so the question is the states that you
end up in are you know
can be different because of you know the
the dynamics
are stochastic which is why we have the
expectation
yeah so in this expression s naught is
not random because we
we have condition s naught to be
something and that s
s that is you know parameter to the
function so s naught here is not random
because it is given
all the future s one s two are random
right so we can now rewrite this
in a slightly different way you know by
actually recognizing that s naught is
[Music]
not random and so we can rewrite this
as r of s because s naught was just
equal to s
plus
gamma times
sum over s prime
in s
p of s
pi of s
s prime
v pi of
how did we go from this equation to this
equation
so the way we went from this equation to
this equation
is by recognizing the fact that
this this expression can be now written
as
r of s
plus gamma times
expectation of r of
s 1 plus
plus r of s 1 plus gamma time r of
s two plus gamma times gamma square
times r of s three
and so on right because this was
this was not random we took it out and
all of these terms have a gamma
so we take the gamma factor out and what
we end up with
is is is
the expectation over all of these and
this we again recognize that
this whole thing over here is
right so this whole thing is just v pi
of s one
right and by making this this ah by
recognizing this recursive pattern
we can define this recursive statement
that v pi of
s is equal to the immediate reward that
we obtain by being at s
plus the discounted ah you know the
discount factor times
the expectation of the future values for
of each particular state you know
times the probability that we end up in
that state by taking the action
right and the action that we take is
according to the policy
this question
yes so the s primes are the immediate
successor states right
so um we are at uh
just for the fact that we are in state s
we earn
rfs and once we at r of s
we take some action according to pi of s
the policy tells us what action to take
and
by taking this action we can end up with
one of the all possible
future states or the successor states
that we denote by s prime
and the and for landing in one
particular s
prime we earn you know v pi of s prime
as
as the as the future value right and so
the overall value of a state can be
decomposed into these two parts the
immediate part
and everything else that follows this
question
yeah so the notation here this is uh the
transition probability that's p
s a a here is pi of s
you are following ah the policy of what
action to take
right and so this is p s a think of this
as p s a
and p s a is a probability
ah a probability function over all the
states
so p s a of s prime tells you the
probability of
ending in s prime if you were in state s
and took action pi of s
right and depending on which state we
end up in we get an appropriate value
out of it
and so this is just the expected value
of taking expected future value of
taking
action according to pi of s this
question
uh can you can you repeat the question
again
so v pi s is so uh so there was this
expectation here
right in this expectation here we could
take r of s naught out
because this was not random right and
what we end up with that is the rest
over here we're just calling this v
pi s yeah it's the expected value yeah
yeah the x s1 through you know s1 s2 s3
are still random
and so we need to still have the
expectation there
right and this equation you know
v pi s where v is is
defined recursively right so we have v
on the left and v on the right
this recursive equation is also called
the bellman equation
right and let us put a box because this
is important
right so to quickly summarize we have
these
two central concepts called policy and
value
right policy is just what actions we
want to take when we are in a given
state
it's a simple function nothing fancy
there
value is this long term extension of
reward
right reward is this short-term
short-sighted
immediate immediate gratification
gratification that we're going to get by
you know being in a particular state
whereas value is this you know long-term
long-sighted
you know what is the what is the total
sum of discounted rewards that we're
going to make in the long term by
following a particular policy
and that is value right so and and this
distinction between
between immediate reward and long term
value is at the heart of reinforcement
learning
because if our goal was to just maximize
the immediate reward we would just be
back in supervised learning setting
right it is because that we want to
maximize this long term reward
where we need to take this long term
view we may need to
make some sacrifices of short-term
rewards in order to
maximize the long-term value and that's
what makes
reinforcement learning hard and makes it
distinct from supervised learning
right
yes question
yes yeah so the so the question is does
this expectation
cover all possible future scenarios yes
it covers all possible future scenarios
where you may win you may lose
your robot may crash right away that
your robot may
land your goal uh you know reach the
particular goal and you know all these
possible scenarios
that may happen by following a
particular policy pie
so our goal which which which we are
going to talk about next
is to come up with a policy that is
going to maximize our values
for for all states any other question
all right
so before we go into into maximizing
these value functions first let's solve
you know given a policy how do we
calculate v pi
right so so the picture to have is
so these two concepts you know value and
policy
you can kind of think of them as the
duals of each other
right so
and there is this kind of
relation between them such that one gets
induced given the other
i should have just erased that never
mind so um
so we have policy
and we have value
right so policy takes us from s
to a right value takes us from
s to r
right and again value is distinct from
reward because reward is immediate
gratification
and value is long-term value
which means in order to maximize value
you may have to sacrifice
immediate rewards if there is a prospect
of doing very well in the long run
right that's that's the key distinction
between reward and value
and given a policy pi
we can calculate the corresponding value
v pi
right so pi takes us from pi to v pi and
we'll see how we're going to do that
and this should be intuitive right if if
if you start from a given state s and
you follow a particular policy
and you follow the same policy over and
over and you repeat such trials
you you know and you average out the
total value uh
you average out all the values that you
end up making
then you know that is v pi right so so
pi
implicitly defines a value function for
each state
and correspondingly from v pi or or
from any value function v you can
construct a corresponding
policy pi where you say that
the action that you are going to take at
a given state
is to the action that you are going to
take at each state
will be to choose the action that gives
you the highest probability
of reaching the next state that has the
highest value
right try to reach the next state which
has the highest value
right and that will that implicitly
defines a policy if you start with a
value function
right so you can go from pi to v pi as
we are going to see next and from v to
pi ah with this with this
in in a somewhat natural way right so uh
given a pi if you if you just follow it
over and over you can you know
find out what v pi is and similarly if
you if you're given a value function if
if you're told that in this
in the in the grid of your map what the
long term value of each one is
and you're in a particular state try to
take an action
that is going to you know with high
probability take you towards
the next state that has the highest
value right
so it's its ah they are kind of duals of
each other
this question
uh can you can you please repeat the
question i think it's about something
about time
yes so the so the the policy
asks you to take a particular action a
when you're in a particular state no
matter how far into the trajectory you
are right now right so you always follow
um so you always follow the same action
when you're in a given state
according to the policy ignoring all the
previous you know
you may have been you may be entering
that state for the first time you may be
entering it for the thousandth time but
if you're following a policy you always
follow the same
same action yes essentially
does not tell you the best possible
value that you can get vp tells you
what's the value that you get by
following this policy
it's not the best possible policy it's
not the best possible value
but how
yeah so we will come to this uh so uh
the the takeaway from here is that
you know there is a relation from going
from pi to v pi
and the relation from going from v to pi
and
and you know uh we're going to uh
clearly define how to do this uh
next so let's
first let's talk about going from phi to
v pi
right and so for that you know from
phi to v pi for this we start with the
bellman's equation
right v pi of s equals
r of s plus gamma
times sum over
s prime in s
p of s pi of s
s prime times v pi of s
right so this is just the bellman
equation i have just written it again
and over here what we see is that
v pi of s assuming we have a finite
number of states
so v pi is a vector right so v pi
is some vector of numbers
that you have real values for each you
know s one s two and so on
right and this is you know ah we we've
kind of
seen this this view before of switching
between
vectors and functions in the past right
so vectors and functions are essentially
one and the same
so think of this v pi of s as a vector
having one you know value value
per state right so
we have v pi so we have v pi
uh of s1 over here
v pi of s2 over here
over here and so on and what this tells
us is now we want to solve for v pi
let's assume we know r of s for every
possible state s
and let's assume we know the transition
probabilities from any state and any
action to any other state
right let's assume we know r p
and gamma so now this is basically
for each s you know for each possible
value of s we get one such
equation where everything is linear and
we can construct a set of linear
equations so if this is s 1
s 1 s
1 s 1 similarly v
pi of s 2 equals
r of s 2 plus
gamma times sum over s prime n
s p s phi
of s 2 of s prime
times v pi of s prime
right and so on all the way until
v pi of s
s equals so here
each of these terms
is a scalar variable that we want to
solve
and there are you know um
there are capital s number of such
variables
and there are capital s number of such
equations
so we have s variables with s number of
right and they are related only with you
know in in a linear way
so all of these are our known constants
and scalars which we are multiplying
right and this can be solved you know
with with any kind of a linear solver
to make this more concrete
let us define this matrix
p pi let me write it a little bit bigger
so let us define p pi
to be
matrix
s so you have one row per state
and one column per state right
and
so p pi ah here each row
is basically p s
phi of s
where s over here indicates the row
number
so let us call this s 1 s 1
this corresponds to s 1 and
s i will give you
p s i pi f
s i right so basically collect all the
transition probabilities
of every p s one and a
right and ah where a is chosen according
to pi
and write it out like a matrix right so
this is just
uh you you we are just selecting a few
of the transition probabilities
where we are starting from a given uh
state
s s i and taking an action according to
pi of s i let's call it a i and this
is p s i a i right
and arrange them into a matrix and call
it p
pi and with that matrix we can
rewrite this in a more compact form as
v pi equals r
plus gamma times
p pi v pi
our question what is is i is i
what does i s i stand for no so this is
the the size of the set s
as many number of states you have right
so we can write this in a compact way
this question
so this is just uh uh so the number of
policies that we have
are uh uh you could have any number of
policies but
we you know we are assuming that we have
psa for every possible sa already
right we are assuming we have the model
we we know the transition probabilities
already
right so all these all these rows and
all the rows the transition probability
that are not included here
we assume we know psa because that's
part of the mdp definition so we have
psa for all combinations of sna yes
questions
over here should it be v v pi s or s
prime
over here it is s prime because we're
taking the expectation
over all future states
oh this should be you're right so you're
sorry yeah this should be s prime
yeah so the s1 only goes into the uh
policy so this should be a sprint thank
you
right so this this set of equations
can be compactly written in vector
notation in this way
right and once we write it in this way
we immediately get
so move this over to the other side and
invert it we get
v pi equals
i minus gamma p pi
inverse r so
this is a vector of size
s this is a vector of size s
this is s cross s
it's a matrix this is the matrix that we
constructed here
and v pi is again it's the same v pi
over here
size s right so take this to the other
side
invert it and we get this
right so this gives us a way of
starting from a policy pi and
calculating
the long term values for each of the
states if we
follow that policy at all times
right so this is
this arrow so ah call it one
this is one
right so accord according to the policy
that we have
we are going to end up with a different
p p pi
and plug that p pi in here rs are given
gamma is given
and you know ah calculate this we get v
pi
this question
yes so each row over here tells you
if we are at state s i
and we take an action according to pi of
s i
what are the set of all possible states
that we can go to with
you know corresponding probabilities
right so this tells us how to go from
policy to
value
yes
no we are not making an assumption that
we cannot go back to the state we can
always
come back to the same state again there
is no such restriction
so the question is will we not converge
we will converge and we will see why we
will convert shortly
right so this is this is ah
right so this yeah this is that how to
go from policy
uh to value right so the policy
according to different policies we get a
different p matrix
because we choose different rows
according to the corresponding actions
and you plug that matrix in
construct this you know this related
matrix invert it
multiply it with r you get get v pi
right so now um
we can also define what is called as
this
you know so recognizing the fact that we
can now you know
given a policy we can construct the
value function let us
move on to define something related we
will come to the other arrow
shortly
all right
so
so we also define what is called as the
optimal value function
so the optimal value function is defined
as
v star of s
is equal to max
over pi v
phi of s
right so the optimal value function is
defined such that
if we are at a particular state right
by choosing the best possible policy
what is the highest value that we can
obtain right so v pi of s tells us
what is the the long term payoff
long term disc sum of discounted rewards
or the expected sum of discounted
rewards
that we are going to get if we follow
the policy pi and v
star of s is tells us you know what is
the maximum possible value that you can
get
across all possible policies pi
right
yes you know here so the question is
here is
s the initial state yes so the
definition of value function is
when assuming you are at the current
state it doesn't matter whether this is
the initial state or you somehow
landed here if we start at
a particular state s no matter what the
history was
or even if it's the first state what is
the expected sum of
future future words right
so v star s is defined as the maximum
possible value
that you can get by searching over the
entire policy space
right and v star of s can
is therefore is also written as
r of s plus
max a in
a gamma times
s prime in s
p s a
s prime times v
star of s prime
right so v star of s is
defined as the max of v pi of s where v
pi of s
we used this definition
we plugged in this definition into v pi
of s
and note that r of s
is a constant that does not depend on a
and does not depend on pi because
the policy only tells us what's going to
happen in the future whereas the reward
is what we already got
so it's going to be r of s plus max
of ao in the action space what is the
action that we need to take
such that we maximize the sum of the
future rewards this equation
looks pretty similar to the original
bellman equation
except the the difference is that here
instead of
pi of s we are maximizing over
a in in place of ps pi of s we have ps
of a
and you are maximizing over a and the
other difference is that
v pi of s because this was for v pi of s
we had v pi of s here
but and over here because this is where
we start of s you know by the recursive
definition we have star of s here
now this the bellman's equation we saw
that we can
express this in a nice linear form
and obtain a closed form solution
you know to uh uh to
to ah to obtain v pi
however v star of s because of this max
operator
it is just not possible to solve it
linearly
right so if you are given a policy it's
very easy to calculate the long-term
value according to that policy
but to calculate the best possible value
or v-star or the optimal value function
it's not it's not as easy as solving a
linear system
right and
it is it is um
and we saw how we can go from pi pi
policy to v pi using this approach now
here
we will see how we can go from a value
function back to a policy right
so this is the optimal value function
that you know we are
interested in or strive to to calculate
and given this v pi of s
we can define the corresponding pi star
of s to be the optimal policy
to be equal to arg max
a in a same thing over here
sum over s prime in capital s
p s a
of s prime times v star
of s prime
so the optimal policy tells us that
the action that we need to take at state
s
is basically the same action that
achieved
the optimal value for us
so the question is why is this hard to
solve because you know we have a limited
number of
a's and and uh you can you so yeah so in
in in cases where
um in cases where you have
um a finite state space and action space
you can iteratively calculate this
so this involves iteration whereas
the the ah for v pi there was no
iteration you had a direct close form
solution
by hard i meant there is no close form
right so this is the optimal value
function and this is the
optimal policy
right so the optimal policy is defined
as the policy that will achieve the
optimal value function for us
right so it's it's it because it
achieves the optimal value function
because
you know we are using the exact same
action
at each state that's going to maximize
the same right hand side
right so this is
we started with the two concepts policy
and value
we started with policy and value like
these two are two
very central concepts right and
given a policy we can calculate
the corresponding value function that
you get by just following the policy
with this closed form expression
and similarly for any given value
function
we can define a policy
that takes action that maximizes
the the expected value based on the
given value function estimate
right and when we use the optimal value
in place we get the optimal policy
right so this is how we move from
value function to policy
now with these two observations we can
now come up with
two algorithms to
to actually calculate v star of s so
this is just ah
you know this is just a mathematical
expression this is not an algorithm of
how to calculate
right so this is just giving you a
relation between
that v star needs to satisfy so this is
a necessary condition
that v star needs to satisfy
if if v star is the optimal value
function right so this is a necessary
condition it's not telling you
how to calculate v star of s
and this is the optimal policy
corresponding to v star
so now we are going to look at two
algorithms now one of them is
is called value iteration the other is
called policy iteration that will help
us
calculate v star of s and pi star of s
so policy iteration that is the next
topic
sorry not policy test value iteration
so the value iteration is an algorithm
right so this is an algorithm it tells
us how to compute its not just a
mathematical relation which is
a necessary condition right so this
tells us how to compute so
step one for
each state
s
initialize v of
s equal to zero
into
repeat until
convergence
for every
state s
update
v of s equal to
r of s plus
max a in
a gamma sum over s prime
p s a of s prime
v of s prime
so initialize initialize
uh your value function to be 0
everywhere at all states
right and then for every state s
update v of s according to this equation
and this equation is the same necessary
condition that we have
according to according to the optimal
value condition
right so if if we have the optimal val
optimal value
then v of s would have satisfied this
but we're going to you know pretend that
um
v pi of v of s is is the optimal value
and and and and by taking that
that uh necessary condition we're going
to construct an update rule
now the question is why will this
converge will this even converge
right we we took a necessary condition
right it's just a condition
and converted into an update rule where
on the right hand side we have the old
value
and you plug it in you know and we set
it to the you know
to be equal to the left hand side and
update v of s
why is this even expected to converge
and the reason why it i know the proof
is is
beyond the scope but i can you know
offer a quick sketch of how how it works
so this update rule that we have over
here
is also called the bellman
update operator or the bellman backup
operator
right so the word operator is
interesting
that's because supposing we have
s one s s
right so you might remember how how we
visualized
functions as points in space you know we
have done it several times in the past
right so supposing we have a function we
have a policy or
sorry supposing we have um
some ah value function v pi that we
represent as
you know a point in a space where each
axis corresponds to a difference
ah to a state right and v pi of s
is basically the you know the coordinate
along s one is v pi of s 1 call later on
s 2 is
v pi s 2 you know the same way we have
been
viewing functions as points in space so
supposing this is the value function
and we plug that v pi of s
into this operator on the right hand
side and
get something else on the left hand side
right we take that v pi run it through
this operator
and you know that we obtain some output
right this is the update rule
right now supposing we start here
and this is the uh
so i'm going to call this b of v pi
which means
this is the output of applying the
bellman backup operator
right now there is a proof that is
beyond the scope of this course
that this bellman operator is
what is called as the technical term for
it is called a contraction mapping
so what a contraction mapping means is
take
any two input points
you know let us call this v prime of pi
or let's just call it um v pi and let's
call it
a v v
v pi two they call this v pi one and v
pi two
and the bellman operator
uh so the bellman backup operator when
you apply on the two of them
you get two different b of
v pi two and the bellman opera ah update
operator
is called a contraction mapping because
for any two inputs to the operator
the corresponding outputs will be closer
to each other than the corresponding two
inputs so
and and this can be this can be you know
shown mathematically
with with you know some simple rules you
apply this and you can prove that the
bellman operate
the bellman backup operators are
contraction mapping and
when something is a contraction mapping
there exists something called as a fixed
point so the intuition there is
for any two any two points you are you
know uh
run them through the bellman operator
you know you get two you know the two
output points will always be closer than
the two input points
and that holds for any two points in the
entire space
right and when you have such a
contraction mapping
the points to which they are all
converging to is called a fixed point
right and it is called a fixed point
because once you reach the fixed point
and you apply the bellman operator on it
you get the same point again
right and this fixed point is called v
star
is v star that's the optimal value
function right so
start with any initialization we started
with zero right we started at zero
it does not have to be zero you start at
any other point you want
and you keep applying this bellman
backup operator over and over
recursively you take the uh you start
from the initialization apply the
operator get an output
apply it back into the bellman operator
you get an output and so on
and we will keep following you know this
this kind of a path where eventually
we're going to converge to v star
and the reason we're going to converge
to v star is because you can prove
that the bellman backup operator is what
is called technically a contraction
mapping
right so it it it kind of contracts this
the entire space towards
a single fixed point anyway though so
the proof is beyond
beyond the scope but it's good to have
this intuition that what's happening
over here this right hand side
corresponds
to this b mapping this contraction
mapping where the entire space is
converging towards
v star right so this is
the value iteration right so start with
some random initialization
we know p uh we we know all the all the
p values we know all the r values
and you keep applying this over and over
until it converges right and when you
converge
you would have reached v star on the so
called fixed point
after which even if you apply the
bellman operator the output is going to
be the same
so the bellman operator takes you one
step
iteration of that one application yes so
one
application of this for all the states
is one bellman operator
and anywhere in the state uh
yes it is a convex form exactly so it is
a convex problem no matter where you
start
and you keep recursively applying the
bellman operator you will keep
you know hopping and hopping and hopping
and reach the same fixed point yeah
right so that's that's a value iteration
and and and this proof is beyond the
beyond the scope but you need to know
the you know
value iteration itself the algorithm
itself
and then there is uh another algorithm
that is called the policy iteration
and in the nodes in fact there are two
variants of the
value iteration that's called the
synchronous and asynchronous so in
in the synchronous we calculate the the
left hand sides for all states as a
temporary variable and
you know replace it in one shot whereas
in asynchronous
you update it for one variable and use
the updated variable for updating the
other variables
right that's a slight variable
and now we come to the second algorithm
called the policy iteration
so in policy iteration this is a
different approach
here we start with the policy right so
initialize
high randomly
as i said in rl you have these two
central concepts the value function and
the policy right
so this approach used the value function
and
kept updating the value function kept
hopping the value function
here we start with the policy right the
other central concept
in rl and two step two
repeat
until convergence
a set
v equal to
v phi
and b for
each state s
set
phi of s
equal to
r max a in
a sum over s
prime p
s a of s prime times
v of s prime
right so start with some initial
estimate for pi right
and probably erased it
we saw how given a pi we can
we have a closed form expression for
calculating v
right you just solve a linear system of
equations so start with the random pi
calculate the corresponding value value
function
and then using that value function
update your policy
such that you're taking steps where you
are
maximizing your expected future rewards
using the current
value function estimate right and then
that gives us a new policy using that
new policy update v
and then using the updated v update pi
and so on right
now what is the difference between these
two methods
so we can make a few observation so
first of all in
[Music]
value iteration
all we are doing is for each
for each state in the value function we
are performing
a max over um
over a capital s number of you know
items
right so you can think of the
computational complexity as
this will be order
capital s square approximately is that
right
so for each state we take a max
over so i think this will be o
s square times a action space
right whereas over here
this step involves
inverting ah s by s matrix
right you remember there was an inverse
where
v equals identity minus
gamma p by
inverse of r
right so this involves inverting an
s bias matrix and so
ah this is order approximately
s cube
and this this step is
approximately order
o of you know action space
times state space
right so for large state spaces
policy iteration can be much more
expensive
than value iteration
however with policy iteration
after a finite number of steps we get
the exact optimal value
right whereas with this we keep getting
closer and closer
and we keep getting closer and closer
but we
may never reach the exact v star
but with policy iteration after a fixed
number of steps
we will recover the exact v star
after some number of steps this question
so the question is are we converging in
terms of v or in terms of policy
uh both both are you know you can use
both the conditions
um it is easier to check in terms of
policy because it's discrete
with this so once once your policy
converges
it it's going to stay converged
yeah so so the way to check convergence
here is first you know
um make a copy as you know
pi prime of the full policy
you know update the new policy and check
if you know for
every element wise does pi prime equals
pi of s for every s and if it is then
you know your policy hasn't changed at
all after a full update
and you know then you can declare
yourself as converged
yeah it can take 11 iterations it can
take you know some number of iterations
but
there is a proof that we are not going
to go over it that this will converge in
a finite number of steps
whereas this has this you know
this this contraction mapping will take
you closer and closer to an arbitrary
degree of precision of your choice but
you may never actually reach
v star but with this once your pi
converges
the converged pi will be pi star
and once you have pi star you can
recover the exact v star
next question
so once we reach or if we use value
iteration
and we reach ah and and we converge to
some
you know v let's not call it v star
let's call it v
prime then you can use the v prime
and recover the corresponding policy by
using v prime here
right so this is taking you from value
function to policy
right and this takes you from policy to
value function
in practice we will use whether you use
policy iteration or value iteration
if our end goal is to recover the
optimal policy we will end up using both
these equations
uh both these equations in
value iteration we apply we
we use this over and over and in the end
extract the policy according to this
equation
and in case of policy iteration uh
we apply this over and over and uh
the the the value function uh
pi to v is is used in step a and in step
b we extract the
policy according to that updated value
function
this question can you do value
yeah so the question is can we can we
run value iteration for some number of
iterations and then
switch over to a policy iteration
yeah so if it has mathematically
converged to right answer
then performing one val policy iteration
and x
uh extracting uh v star will give you
the same v star
right both both the algorithms take you
to the same v star and same pi star
in this case after a finite number of
steps you get an exact v-star
you know as soon as your policy stops
changing the corresponding value
function is the
exact v star with value iteration
you get arbitrary close to v star you
know depending on how many steps you
have but you may never
get the exact v star by only following
this approach
yes
so the intuition of why this is expected
to converge is right here
right so think of the bellman update
operator as some kind of a contraction
mapping
the proof of why it's a contraction
mapping is is beyond the scope and it is
pretty easy to show actually you can you
can try it on your own um
and if you're interested i can post a
proof on piazza
but the bellman update operator is a
contraction mapping and once you prove
it
you know you get the intuition that uh
contraction map
contraction mappings have a fixed point
and if you keep repeatedly applying
that operator over and over to the same
input you know and then
applying it to the output and then
applying to its output it's going to
take you towards the fixed point
and that's exactly why this will
converge we're going to
cover a few more simple extensions to
the policy
iteration and value iteration what is
something called as the
fitted value function and we're going to
cover a quick overview of the
larger reinforcement learning field as a
whole
we won't be getting into any other
methods for your homework
these what we're going to cover until
the middle of
next friday will be sufficient for the
reinforcement learning part of whatever
is going to come in your
homework but the rest of the
reinforcement learning will be just for
you know for your information
all right thanks
you